der zweite mit dem hus
eine frau gestorben ist wo längere zeit
mit kundenbeschwerden
das bedeutet dass es objektive zurück so
geklappt hat und sie selber musik stört
und was kommt egal ob mit denen stefan
klima wird jemals gerufen wenn jemand
gestorben ist
königs im kanton bern ist schauplatz
dieses filmes doch er könnte auch
woanders spielen denn einsame menschen
trifft man hinter mancher fassade
[Musik]
der fang china von der gemeinde köniz
beginnt mit seiner arbeit
die polizei war bereits hier und auch
jemand vom institut für rechtsmedizin
ein verbrechen konnte ausgeschlossen
werden
die leiche wurde abgeholt
ansonsten ist noch alles unberührt hoch
über seine hier das es braucht nicht
packe ich mit dem rückschnitt und da
kann man sehen dass das letzte nicht sie
wo die verstorbene gast und wiegt
weil die damals über ricardo yorker taxi
orange alina liegt darin dagegen gestand
und aus werken gestand bedeutet das dass
sie da wie immer und nach und nach auch
interessensverbände
stefan china ist so genannter siege
lungs verantwortlicher da sie mich
nachher sagt sache
zu seinen aufgaben gehört es den
nachlass von verstorbenen
sicherzustellen china protokolliert
sämtliche wertgegenstände damit sie
niemand an sich nimmt der zugang zur
wohnung haben könnte mit den nachbarn
und dem arbeitgeber der verstorbenen hat
er bereits gesprochen
sie war mitte 50 und architektin dass
sony besitzers und die rufe mir mit dem
besucher vor dem haus da hier das sie
noch mehr wichtige sache für medien
finden was sie besitzen wollen erfahrung
bringen ist dass die frau sehr einsam
ich sie dass sie hier mit der nachbar
der kontakt der eigentlichen verweigere
und was ich hier sehe aber sie vor ihrem
rookie sachse ist dass die frau
definitiv für alkoholprobleme kann und
dass sie nachher oder von moskau das
ganze basiert dass sich die direkten
zusammenhang mit an mich gesehen
konfrontiert mit solch traurigen
todesfällen macht sich china und
willkürlich gedanken darüber was hier
abgelaufen ist
das hier ist der todesort vor der frau
genau wie ich sie empfunden wurde
das ist kein blut das ist rot wie also
was ich hier gebrochen
das bringt gar nicht bewusst es ist mit
beruf immer sehr ich es auch gewöhnt ruf
der andere sieht muss ganz klar sagen
das tut ihm weh wenn man merkt
respektive passau beweis
also tage lang nicht vermisst wird und
das ist dann so im energie- und das ist
das wo er bleibt
auf spurensuche geht china auch als
persönlichem interesse der gewinne fiel
an lebenserfahrung wenn er in
menschliche abgründe blicken sagt er
dass jedes bett fixiert dass hier das
ganze mit dass sie da im rezept und
hätte nach ihrem schlafzimmer normal
verlag für mich sieht die spur wo zum
ruhm musiker ganz klar das indiz dafür
dass sie hier neulich im finish hoch
hier vor der stadt gestanden ist unter
alkoholeinfluss sauber nach altrich
verloren hat und aber kritisch nachdem
die architektin tage lang nicht zur
arbeit erschienen war alarmierte ihr
vorgesetzter die polizei angehört er
hatte die architektin keine die
wertgegenstände kommen einer stiftung
zugute das hat die verstorbene in ihrem
testament angeordnet
isoliert lebende menschen würden oft
auch dinge horten erzählt der siegelung
verantwortlich er stehe immer wieder in
wohnungen waren mensch einsam gestorben
ist
die labors von denen rund 400 todesfall
mit hagman kam jetzt die neue bezahlt
sein team vor der messe präsent dass das
getriebe aber sie sich nicht meldet
[Musik]
jeder vierte im alter fühlt sich einsam
frauen sind häufiger betroffen als
männer zu diesem schluss kommt eine
studie des bundesamtes für statistik
ein blick hinter die fassade des königs
alters und pflegeheim stapfen
[Musik]
helga klauser verbringt ihre tage
zurückgezogen in ihrem zimmer
[Musik]
ihr ehemann ist vor einigen jahren
gestorben
die 84 jährige leidet unter vereinsamung
obwohl sie eine tochter hat diese ab und
zu besucht
[Musik]
es ist viel leichtere ungerecht wenn man
das wort einsamkeit bucht für die wo ja
einfach telefonieren und für die roma
aber stellte foto gehört einfach am
morgen aus dem bett und nachher gar
einfach hier eine sache nach rasse und
sieht einfach von morgen bis am abend in
eurem zimmer oder und wenn wenn wenn das
bedürfnis sagen mit dem pc oder zange
oder darauf im gange einfach baumann hin
und her
oder wenn das wetter schön ist natürlich
auch wenn die spaziere heute jetzt zum
beispiel ein alter da fühlt man sich
nicht mit der operette und sage mal das
bier und ausführlich alle red mit zug
sei und dass das bestehende einsamkeit
über 70 betagte wohnen im alters und
pflegeheim stapfen doch helga klauser
fühlt sich trotzdem alleine ihr fehlt
das vertrauen in andere berufe und das
wird wenn man diskutiert mit und geht
das meistens sache ins negative usa wo
dann rot ihm fernhalte hier wird hier
beende oder der andere nicht
hundertprozentig sympathisch ist mit
allen schritten und da muss man
vorsichtig sie mit dem reden
[Musik]
auf einer art macht man sich
beschäftigen
auf der anderen art ist mir vom alter
einfach zu bequem
ich kann es bis ganz groß mit kantor
johannes bitter da wenn es mal ein wenig
habe immer einfach nimmer diesmal sich
im alter kommt meine situation jener
wenn man jünger ist gar nicht vorstellen
in köniz ist erneut ein mensch gestorben
der verein samt war der siegelung
verantwortliche stefan china suchten der
wohnung des verstorbenen nach
wertgegenständen
das ist ja wohl in form einer
alleinstehenden mann zündete jedoch
nicht
das sind froh so genannter trennen nach
guten haye ist jemand sah max herre
kenny king und die frau ist vor zehn
jahren gestorben
china erfuhr von den nachbarn dass sie
den mann kommen gesehen hatte nachdem
seine frau gestorben war vor zwei wochen
erlebt der witwe einen schwächeanfall
wohl konnte er noch die ambulanz
alarmieren doch im spital kam für ihn
jede hilfe zu spät
august wird morgen auf einer otto
passieren frau kippte samt hätte sich
nur noch auf das sammeln konzentriert
ist also sehr einsamer mensch sie die
vielen ordner müssen nach wertvollen
briefmarken durchsucht werden
dazu wird der siedlungs verantwortliche
einen experten hinzuziehen
in diesem haus ist einsamkeit dauergast
fertiggerichte tagein tagaus peter
dortschy hat nie gelernt den haushalt
selber zu fühlen
selbst die rechnung zu bezahlen überließ
der 68 jährige seiner frau vor einem
jahr starb sie unerwartet an
herzversagen
aber selbst das mit frau gestorben ist
und mit ihm über die cross hoch ob er
mit dem hammer conny kurth klappe
apotheker so dass die city verfolgte die
mikro machen mails und menü das gesetz
ist gang und ein kochkurs heinz nieweler
belügen
das ist nichts was einfach nichts denkt
sie und die frohe countries ldcs machst
du wofür ist ja ihr schafft bei deportes
sendung vielleicht machen wir da so
wickelt die wohnung verlässt der vito
nur noch selten
seit dem tod seiner frau hat sich peter
chou abgekapselt die ehe blieb kinderlos
fast alle verwandten sind bereits
gestorben
seit vielen jahren sammelt und baut der
ehemalige mechaniker modelle aller art
peter chou freute sich auf die
pensionierung er glaubte mehr zeit für
das hobby und seine frau zu haben
ersetzung zusätzlich mit einem sind dass
man habe nicht mit xamax es ist keine
ganz so optimistisch weniger strom aber
ist sie mit ihm max irrt mir jetzt gar
nichts das ist jetzt einfach da sich
jetzt outen
es ist mir da studiert eigentlich schon
heute für den contest sogar berlin als
die sonne
aber warum muss man sich irgendwie
beschäftigen
november 2008 bedeutete dass ich mich
eben mit seinem exil
ja so viel wie jetzt gelang das ist
schon das ist schon lange tot
eine seiner zwei katzen ist kürzlich
gestorben
und geblieben ist in china
koenigs erhielt vor zwei jahren vom
schweizer heimatschutz den wacker will
ist gelobt wurde die hervorragende
siedlungspolitik aus der ortschaft bei
berlin gibt es aber auch bilder die
weniger schlagzeilen machen bilder die
stefan kiehne archiviert was mir ist
honig oder viele ehemalige verbüßte die
honig vor der frau was ich mit vier
propangas m mit luft gejagt hat der
setzte gemacht
die einsamkeit sie nicht mit sich selbst
am krieg für da setzte die andere
treffer vor glück reden dass der lügt
sie uns nabarro
was ist an die vom tod es kommt vor der
tv serie einsame frau vor der sehr
intelligente frau man das
hochschulstudium hat um den mit sachsen
4 jetzt klar die hätte drogen sie jetzt
versucht der methadon wie die juso sätze
hätte es aber nicht geschafft was mit
jüdisches blut vor der verstorbene
jüngere person mit dem züricher problem
indem sie hätte etwas mehr die vor den
wirkstoffen mit den an kombiniert über
jahren unterseite körper mehr bürger
verliehen und derzeitiges multiples
organversagen und die hätte er nach
einer ecke nicht gefunden
das ist ihrer soll und ist wieder ins
heim beispielsweise mit dem thema wohnen
decken die familie hat ist schon mal
direkt steht das müssen hier weg nach
rom
jeder schritt ist für heidi scheer ich
mit schmerzen verbunden
die 83 jährige leidet an knochenschwund
zur außenwelt hat sie nur noch wenig
kontakt deshalb holte sich die welt ins
haus
zwei familien
[Musik]
in einer gesellschaft in der erfolg und
leistung hoch im kurs stehen ist
einsamkeit oft mit scham besetzt
selina heiniger engagiert sich mit
herzblut für jene die alleine sind hilfe
benötigen
die pflegefachfrau der spitex region
köniz sagt dass jede zweite person die
sie besucht einsam sein
täglich besucht selina einiger beträgt
dabei geht es stets um weit mehr als um
medizinische versorgung für heidi
schiller ist es eine der wenigen
gelegenheiten ihr herz auszuschütten
ihr zweiter mann starb vor einigen
jahren die 83-jährige hat vier kinder
aus erster ehe mit der hand mit einer
handy kein kontakt mit den anderen ja
[Musik]
sie haben den wunsch sich wer sie da
eigentlich wurde hier als telefonist
machen oder privat ist ein verlierer -
100 prozent sicher aber fast wie würdet
ihr reagieren
ich glaube aber die 100 prozent sicher
dass weiß wie schwer es schon komisch zu
sein
gemeinsamkeit gibt es viele gründe es
gibt solche die ihren lebenspartner
verloren haben
[Musik]
manche fühlen sich mitten in
gesellschaft alleine weil sie kein
vertrauen in andere haben
[Musik]
und dann gibt es jene die abgekapselt
leben weil sie mit ihrer familie
gebrochen haben
[Musik]
menschen wie stefan china lernen viele
gesichter der einsamkeit kennen aber
immer erst dann wenn jemand gestorben
ist
[Musik]